サッカーは好きですかあの僕中3の時
バスケ部でバスケ部の引退際の前日の接骨
院であのか足のマッサージしてもらってい
た時に接骨院に行ったの漫画漫画で
キャプテン翼読み続けてばスキーの引退 j
の前日にサッカー部に入れたくなってまし
たこんにちははじめ出張ですはい時で本日
はい14feb の月よりバレンタインて
そして私和美社長の鍛造3でございます
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ますもう29歳あの twitter と
かねほんといろんな方にあのお祝いして
いただいて本当に私幸せものです
ありがとうございます
どうよみんなどう思うよあのは剛雄2羽と
言われればはじめさと言われた時代そこ
からも何年もたってあの外れ社長がもう
29歳来年30
糞耳それは言い過ぎだけども少なくとも4
今の活躍されているいろんな
ユーチューバーさんの中とやっぱり土地上
の方なんですよねお兄さんです私も版その
時代の中でも感じもう20代ベストので
需給歳ということでまぁ目標というかそう
ですねなんか
陸奥駅お値段から土地双方になることが
正しいとも会入らないと思ってて逆にお礼
もなんか20代最後ということで別に何か
も大人っぽくなりたいというわけでもなく
何でも30代になっても愛知三重になって
も何やってるんだともいつまでも肇社長
らしくいたいと思っているのでまぁあの
何かやらかしても大目に見てくれると
ありがたいですというわけで29歳の始め
たぞよろしくお願いします
あんまり見たに変わってないよねがよく
2456暗いと言われるんですけど見た目
に反してなんかボロボロなんでなんだ
変わらないはず目社長もこれから見せて
いければいいなと思っております
b 実は
あの本当は誕生日のカウントダウンあの
サプライズプレゼントみたいなものを
もらったんですけれども本
とにちょっとあの1ちょっとうまく説明
できないほど米うまく説明できないけど今
ただ一つだけ言えることはちょっと今は
出せないということだけちょっとあのお
話しさせてくださいいろんなあの竜があっ
てあの近いうちに必ず動画に出しますので
ぜひ楽しみにしててください外れしたその
事を知ってる人からすると
各最高過去最高の誕生日になっていると
思うのではなぜ楽しみにしててください
チャンネル登録ぜひ宜しくお願いもはいと
いうわけで29戦に弾み冊をそしてランド
いってもここ最近あったことといえば
1000万人チャンネル登録者数到達と
いうことでヴィンター
誕生日ということで
夢たらの誕生日とかでちょっとで告知させ
てくださいただ2にすごい告知だとは思い
ますそうねなんか最近気づいたんですけど
もチャンネル登録者と異性まで行く前
ぐらいからもなんですけど裏でこそこそ
動いていることが多くてねすぐ情報出せ
ないよちょっと悔しいなとは思っている
誕生日ということで今日だけは初めてその
北つ良かったらあの聞いてくれると
ブリッジというわけで羽根3冊のお誕生日
として1000万人記念し目シャル告知
まずはこちらの nv me vtr を
ご覧下さいどうぞ
[音楽]
8名黎伊勢万人一番を made look
ず50って抜ける変えたグラブ
入れはいよろしく
p ええええええええええええええええ
me
いいいいいい
ana
aname
あああああいいいい
あっ
はぁ
cmあっ
はぁame
はっはっは
[音楽]
を曲がっ
er
[音楽]
me
形がたり肩に後へ
串恒子具室だねあとファソ比べだねこれ
ファソクラブありがとうございます的な
告知ムービーでございますありがとう
ございますはい協議で簡単にいうと2つお
知らせがございますまず一つチャンネルと
露出1000万人記念月販売いたします
もうしたしましたギャルと恐竜コラボで
ございますもうあの子何もあるんですけど
もガッツからこちらでもいるんですけども
私が愛してやまでゲルト恐竜っていう
アニメって漫画があるんですけれども
こっちらとコラボさせていただいた商品で
グッズでございますもう
本当にあのずうに俺が欲しいこれが欲しい
んですけど本当にかわいいんですよ t
シャツが2種類でましてこちらハイあの
僕恐竜だとなんだろうなって思ったんです
けどただ来てラーのどんなんですよは金と
腕んじゃないか羽っぽくウミウシなると
プテラノドンぽい感じでいけるとキュウセ
がやっと多分てランドドンになるという
ことでいうとはじめシャツを来てランド
どうもこちらにいますで2シャツ2種類
ございます始めたということでスライムで
遊んでいるやると恐竜の t シャツと
ジャズ2種類やにますいけると恐竜があの
はじめザウルスがいるこのノーマルの t
シャツ白黒と肇社長といえばスライムです
そうつらい御遊んでいるギャルと恐竜たち
とはじめザウスの t シャツ2種類あり
ますでもう一グッズ赤い毛スタンドも販売
されます
靴が3人で仲良く入っている世代袋に入っ
ていると言うこんな嬉しい事あるすっきー
なキャラとのコラボよぜひ t シャツ2
種類とアウディスタンドが2種類ござい
ますね発売は今年の春予定しておりますの
で是非詳細は後日初心のツイッターから
告知しますので
今回そしてもう一つあのファンクラブ
はじめのっていうファンクラブがあるん
ですけどもそちらが8リニューアルあのお
引越ししましたアプリですね今まで最初
だったんだけど当たり日光しましてファ
ミコンって言うここでしか見れないはず3
冊をノアの投稿だったり生配線も実は
たまにやってますグループチャットなんか
みんなでラインみたいなお話とかもでき
ます結構まめに言うとを押してますあと
愚痴を言ってますという裏側知りたいとか
肇社長の中どんな人だろうっていうの気に
なっている方がいらっしゃったら是非
お待ちしてます始めの入るでいろんな
キャンペーンやってたり2月18日まで
入会された人には全員ですね外れ社長の
オリジナルポストカードをプレゼントされ
たりしますのでぜひず3冊方と会えるキア
の街がで増えましたしお話に機械とか何か
良い青年とやりとりする機会も増えると
思うので是非皆さんの初めの入会をお待ち
しておりますやとりあえず俺は葉や花の
ギャルと恐竜の t シャツを着たいって
いう文字が思いますが大きいですはいって
いうせませんと告知便利だったんですけど
誕生日本当にすごいことがあったんですよ
もうすぐ立てるいいのが非常に来やすいな
んですけども使えるって絶対入ってますの
であの是非お楽しみにしてくださいという
わけでに重大なスト大人にだけは俺はなら
ねぇどんな時も youtube を始め
た気持ちを忘れず増
恐れず楽しんで行きたいと思いますこれ
から本当にシャツをよろしくお願います
じゃあ
[音楽]
始め足が1000万人ですよねアムリタを
終えるグッズを競ってるかへ
パンクラブ入りはいよろしく
じゃいっ
me
[音楽]